muito boa tarde muito boa tarde a todas
ea todos
eu queria começar esse meu bate papo com
vocês perguntando o que vão pensar de
mim mas o que vão pensar de vocês também
eu quero fazer um pedido especial faça
uma lista por favor de pessoas que você
acredita que na última semana parar um
pouquinho a sua vida corrida
auto-centrada cheia de compromissos para
elevar o pensamento até você um gesto de
torcida ainda que à distância alguém que
tenha pensado em ti que você crê que
tenha pensado em ti no seguinte sentido
tomara que ele esteja bem tomara que ela
esteja bem eu volto à pergunta o que vão
pensar de mim o que vão pensar que você
siga perguntando ao que ea quem a gente
anda consagrando a nossa vida
há propostas a causas e pessoas que
torcem por nós e nos mobilizam ou as
sombras feias e velhas que são
devoradores de alma de potenciais de
energia de tesão de moradoras da
possibilidade de uma boa vida e porque
não de uma boa morte
eu nasci em cuiabá no mato grosso
mas alguém de cuiabá aqui eu não sei
porque eu ainda faço essa pergunta
cuiabá fica assim perto do pantanal
perto da chapada dos guimarães é muito
quente em cuiabá
mas quando eu falo que é muito quente é
outro nível de quentura da aflita assim
ovo no asfalto e eu fico pensando na
fundação da cidade calcula uma galera
foi para lá por alguma razão
chegando lá eles viram a chapada dos
guimarães que não tinha esse nome porque
nem o guimarães tinha chegado ainda
claro não tinha chegado ninguém então
eles olharam que lugar lindo lá no alto
imagina que vai de massa várias
cachoeiras temperatura muito mais amena
uma vista maravilhosa o centro geodésico
da américa do sul embora ninguém
soubesse disso ainda mas já era mesmo
sem ninguém saber
e aí o pessoal viu lá embaixo um buraco
uma baixada quente quente eles
deliberaram acho que até fizeram dez
evocaram técnicas de design thinking
planejamento estratégico para decidir
que iam fazer a cidade no buraco e o
resto você já sabe eu passei a minha
infância toda boa parte da minha
adolescência em cuiabá que tem duas
estações do ano tem o verão e o inferno
eu posso falar isso porque é o meu lugar
de fala vocês não a infância em cuiabá
foi marcada por muitas coisas
por sorte eu cresci numa casa com muito
amor com muito acolhimento com muito
respeito e com muitos limites também só
que fora de casa e dentro de mim tinha
lugar da minha jornada pessoal e
intransferível que cabia a mim lidar e
eu tinha medo eu tinha muito medo de me
comunicar de me manifestar
eu tinha muito medo do encontro com as
pessoas e eu tinha
em mais quantidade e ainda tenho cabelos
crespos que chamaram tantas vezes de
cabelo ruim
pichai bombril
não são poucas as pessoas que parecem
consagrar as suas vidas
a tentativa de a pequena a vida alheia e
me acertar em alguns momentos claro a
fase da adolescência foi um pouco mais
complicada porque a adolescência é uma
parada estranho você não é mais criança
você também não é adulto você tá tipo
num limbo etário é um livro que é a
adolescência é coisa de gente corajosa
de gente descolada a gente atirada e eu
tinha medo e eu fumei apequenando me
escondendo cada vez mais o efeito
colateral positivo foi um mergulho na
leitura eu fiz um dos brothers e umas
brothers massa eu comecei fernando
pessoa
dostoiévski nishan 1 saúde eu conhecer a
irmã s adélia prado virginia woolf gente
da pesada talvez um pouco precoce demais
vamos conhecer mas me ajudaram a
compreender melhor aquilo que eu vivia
eu cresci em cuiabá na escola assim como
a maioria de vocês e até hoje eu estou
buscando tirar a escolarização de dentro
de mim
não há educação a escolarização um
método prussiano do século 18 que desde
então vem cumprindo com louvor a sua
idéia de formar para a indústria para a
guerra
mais recentemente para o consumo eu
entrei na faculdade aos 17 anos em são
paulo e três coisas embasaram a decisão
na escolha do curso superior
três coisas bastante vigorosas como
vocês perceberam uma eu gostei do nome
do curso
comunicação social 2
a faculdade é um conceito bom no guia do
estudante
nem sei se existe mais negócio e 3
a faculdade ficava no bairro que minha
família tinha morado há 30 anos então
óbvio que é uma referência direta de bom
lugar 30 anos depois o local chamado
mary anne led e não conhece a vila
mariana em são paulo
eu entrei na escola superior de
propaganda e marketing
achando que eu ia fazer um curso de
comunicação social
mas é o seguinte é propaganda e
marketing é o nome da parada mesmo tipo
seu antunes sabe o seu antunes que
ninguém sabe o primeiro nome todo mundo
chama de antunes
então era propaganda e marketing
comunicação social foi o que eu não
aprendi na faculdade do jeito que eu
achei que era como é que eu vou
descobrir como chegar perto do outro
como fazer ponte pra falar e ouvir não
foi na faculdade que eu aprendi nada
contra o curso nada contra o curso até
porque parece que ele é bom no que ele
se propõe a fazer que é propaganda e
marketing
eu saí da faculdade com o diploma que eu
não lembro como conseguir e com uma
filha caminho que eu lembro
o fato é que eu estava em 1999 que
acabaram fazendo estágio tinha acabado
de ser efetivado no programa trainee de
uma multinacional eu ganhava olha só
como eu tinha potencial eu ganhava em
1999 sem corrigir tal monta lá no
holerite cebolão next e abre chora é eu
ganhava 2 mil e setecentos reais em 1999
eu tinha carro da firma padrão carteira
assinada eu tinha tíquete-alimentação
daquele de papel que destacava assim né
esse roteiro da instrumentalização da
escolarização parecida sendo cumprido
com muito louvor na verdade só que não
eu sentia uma progressiva perda de ânimo
de tensão pela vida eu ia trabalhar cada
vez menos a cada dia eu descobri é ali
que o absenteísmo custa muito menos que
o presenteísmo o sujeito que vai não vai
era o meu caso eu percebi uma fraude
eu percebia alguém que estava
desrespeitando acordos tanto o acordo
que eu tinha no meu íntimo de fazer
valer a minha vida quanto o acordo com
aquela empresa que bom mas não importa
tanto importa que eu tinha feito um
acordo e eu não estava cumprindo fazendo
o melhor que eu podia
eu estava treinando para ser medíocre 14
horas por dia e certamente quem treina
14 horas para qualquer coisa vai
conseguir sucesso
eu precisava sair daquele local a minha
esperança era a seguinte estava todo
mundo dizendo que estava certo que o
mundo ia acabar no ano 2000
não sei se vocês lembram disso talvez
não mas o mundo acabar dava certo em
2000 acaba no mundo então em 99 eu
estava meio que ligou falou mas vou
mexer pra que vai acabar mesmo
então eu estava contando com o fim do
mundo de fora para não ter que lidar com
o desacerto do mundo de dentro
só que deu bosta não acabou o mundo de
fora alguma empreiteira zicou e tal e
que não fez a obra acontecer não
aconteceu e eu tive que escutar o que
marguerite yourcenar a pensadora belga
dizia que nosso verdadeiro local de
nascimento
nosso verdadeiro momento de nascimento é
quando a gente lança um olhar sincero
sobre a gente mesmo e ali eu tive que
entender o sentido da prontidão que eu
fui conhecer o teatro como o sentido da
técnica da prontidão de estar onde você
tá italy atento disponível por ozu
interessado com vontade de viver a vida
que está levando até pra sair da
tragédia que por ventura você esteja
passando eu precisava estar no local
onde estava então eu pergunto a você o
quanto você está onde você está
sem isso é muito difícil a gente
compreender o que se chama auto
percepção que estar onde eu estava eu
não tava onde estava a maior parte do
tempo eu não tava eu precisava
descontraí sair do lugar da contração do
lugar do apequenamento neste
descolamento da alma e do contexto eu
estava desanimado porque anima é o latim
pra alma em português eu estava
desanimado numa rotina progressiva que
não era intermitente porque tem dia que
está mais firme entende que está menos
firme tendência mais firme e isso é um
gráfico de vida num monitor de uma uti
quando você vê isso acontecer é vida
se você vê não é um bom índice
então eu precisava descontrair eu
precisava me lagostera a eu queria me
sentir em foi derramado
é um conceito um pouco mais descolado e
ousado do empoderamento é o
empoderamento eu queria me sentir fora
pela primeira vez na vida não mais [ __ ]
que você não isso eu queria me sentir
falta de preferência com ph que é mais
chique chique com y porque eu falei da
lagosta
você calcula uma coisa se eu já tinha
gasto na infância do que iam pensar de
mim se imagina no início da vida adulta
com uma filha com um punhado de
responsabilidades
um punhado ainda maior de expectativas a
respeito da minha vida eu não tava com o
cagaço eu estava com uma constrição
esfincteriano ana quase que é impossível
de ser mas eu não podia ficar ali sabe
onde eu descobrir um caminho que me
ajudou
não não agosto a lagosta foi uma
inspiração tardia porque ela gosta desse
bicho que algumas pessoas parece que
como eu fico pensando quem viu a lagosta
primeira vez que eu quero colocar isso
na minha boca
deve ter sido muito necessidade não é
exatamente uma coisa é ergonomicamente
só que ela gosta um bicho inteligente
que elas ela ensina algo a todos nós
muito mais inteligente que a gente
porque quando ela nem fazer uma um
processo de transição e eu precisava pra
sair daquele apequenamento de forma
minimamente justa com as pessoas com as
quais interage antt a gente que dependia
de mim tem uma pequena muito
pequenininha na época que dependia de
mim eu precisava de um plano de
transição porque essa coisa de vou meter
o marlon brando e sair pela tipo não ia
rolar pra mim é deixar um rastro de
miséria e é bom só pra mim e pra ele não
funciona protagonismo sem ética não
rolava isso infelizmente cola - ainda a
lagosta vai para debaixo das pedras para
soltar cascavel ela e para ganhar casca
nova pra caber um pouco mais dela
só que ela vai para debaixo da pedra que
o lugar mais seguro no plano de
transição então eu pedi demissão da
firma cara eu pedi demissão da
multinacional e peguei uma representação
comercial porque foi o meu plano de
transição eu queria continuar fazendo um
processo marcado por respeito a quem
estava perto de mim
apesar de precisar me respeitar cada vez
mais e ganhei um pouco mais de tempo
para investigar o que eu queria fazer da
vida porque o sócrates não e se o que
morreu agora há pouco tempo o irmão do
raí não é esse o outro aquele que era
filho de eta eta eta a parteira ferrar
eta é guardar o nome da mulher assim seu
nome esquisito o sogra dizia ou a gente
encontra um destino a cumprir ou algum
outro destino qualquer vai arrastar a
gente pela vida pelos cabelos
olha que forte isso esse mesmo cara
disse pra gente aprender a viver
primeiro a gente tem que aprender a
morrer é o desapego a capacidade de se
transformar esse lagostera a eu
precisava encontrar a causa porque sem
causa é difícil ter protagonismo sem
estar apaixonado é difícil sair do lugar
comum sair da rotina é muito difícil em
movimento sem amor por algo e eu
encontrei no universo do palhaço se você
não gosta de falar e palhaços falha do
clown 1 se você não gosta do clown pode
chamar o elemento circense promotor da
ilegalidade é pode chamar do que quiser
mas o fato é que no cloud descobrir uma
coisa maravilhosa que era possibilidade
de ser um perdedor feliz
olha que coisa revolucionária que a ana
vôo escreveu uma pensadora sobre o
universo do palhaço perdedor feliz sabe
porque se tem uma certeza e isso é uma
certeza não é generalizar se tem uma
certeza que vamos perder perder perder
perder até a perda final fato se fato
está dado como eu lido com o fato de
forma melhor
vamos perder mas como podemos perder mas
bella mente com mais dignidade enchendo
- o saco do mundo
como eu posso perder e seguir de forma
exuberante como eu posso consagrar a
vida ao congraçamento que é o
compartilhamento de graça e eu fui com o
palhaço para dentro do hospital e no
hospital e vencer coisas incríveis e
silenciando coisas incríveis
há 17 anos eu frequento
mas principalmente na grande são paulo
mas já estive mais de 200 no brasil
inteiro em outros sete países
uma turma do campo cidadão ong que eu
participei da fundação e ainda hoje faça
a gestão os programas sócio-culturais
nós já visitamos mais de 3 milhões de
pessoas em hospitais escolas e outros
locais na crença na possibilidade do bom
encontro pela arte pela vida no hospital
eu descobrir que nós somos pacientes e
cuidadores em tempo integral
simultaneamente esse é o conceito mais
poderoso de ética é quando eu compreendo
que sou paciente mas também sou o
cuidador esse conceito de ética que vai
além das chuvas prudência as
ilegalidades envolvidas mas é muito mais
simples é compartilhar nossa
inteligência para melhorar a convivência
e são tantas as formas de inteligência
mas fundamentalmente buscando respeitar
o que uma das mulheres mais fortes da
antiguidade na literatura chamada
'antígona' disse que ela tinha nascido
para o amor e para garantir o direito
inalienável que qualquer ser nascer
viver e morrer com dignidade e honra a
isso o antigo na consagrou a sua vida ea
sua morte e dentro do hospital eu
aprendi que a gente faz isso no
cotidiano é na etiqueta não essa bobagem
de mexer com um talher mas a etiqueta
dos bons encontros a pequena ética
daquilo que a gente faz é o que
interessa porque é onde a vida acontece
numa tarde de terça-feira é ali que a
vida acontece pra valer o resto é ilusão
e bem com palhaço dentro do hospital
também entende que rir não é o melhor
remédio rir não é o melhor remédio é um
excelente remédio ou um excelente
patrocinador de bons encontros se for
baseado no respeito incondicional ao
lugar do outro aí a gente sai da ego
trip de causar riso no outro e se torna
fundador de ponte para visitar e para
ser visitado com o canto cidadão também
eu descobri que a gente tem que
descontrair a nossa identidade
como pessoa e como país
quero contar duas coisas pra vocês que
são um pouco antagônicas mas que
precisam ser olhados com o mesmo
interesse
o google o ano passado eu achei muito
massa quando ele fez isso divulgou uma
notícia que pela primeira vez na
história do brasil
a expressão cabelos cacheados foi mais
buscada que cabelos lisos e os 12 meses
anteriores a agosto de 2017 232 por
cento de aumento na busca por cabelos
cacheados em relação a tempos anteriores
e nos últimos 24 meses a partir de agora
309% de buscas a mais por cabelos afro
um país está buscando descontração da
sua identidade sair da contração um país
tão miscigenado
isso é um indício e não é um indício
banal não é um indício de identidade em
descontração
além disso a outra pesquisa feita pela
ipsos em 38 países coloca o brasil em
penúltimo lugar e esse não é uma boa
notícia mas é necessário a gente ainda
saber
respeitamos mas a pesquisa do índice da
percepção equivocada o brasileiro ficou
em penúltimo lugar de 38 países
daqueles que menos têm noção do que
acontece à sua volta
ou seja o processo tá alienação de estar
alheio à realidade do contexto em que eu
vivo e essa é a necessidade de
descontrair mas cada vez mais que diz
construirmos cada vez mais um cotidiano
velho e aí seguindo pra nossa reta final
de papo eu queria fazer uma pergunta pra
você pra deixar o emanuel kant felizão
levanta a mão eu não vou enxergar cantor
nem vendo vocês aqui mas levanta a mão o
tanto que você gosta de ser cuidada
respeitada reconhecida como se fosse um
termômetro a sua mão quanto mais alto
melhor mostra pra mim por favor deixa eu
ver quanto você gosta mãos muito ao alto
bacana pode descer agora a pergunta que
fica é o quanto você e aí eu peço que
repita um gesto
acima sinceridade que você consegue o
quanto você já cuida já reconhece já
respeita à frente o que você acredita
ser capaz e necessário
por favor mostrem se á na mesma altura
que você demandas e cuidados e
reconhecido percebo muita diferença é
esse delta essa distância que nós
precisamos trabalhar desconstroem
desconstruindo a nossa nosso cotidiano
velho descontraindo nossa identidade pra
que a gente possa junto fazer esse gap
diminuir entre aquilo que eu ofereço e
aquilo que eu te mando porque eu falei
do cante porque antes dizia que a nossa
maioridade existencial vem quando a
gente pára e se acha vítima e passa a
ser cuidador também quando a gente passa
a ser cuidar e ser cuidado aí a gente
começa a afundar um novo e eu quero
também dizer a vocês que o meu pai me
contava uma história que eu achava que
era mentira mas que pode ser verdade
como uma inspiração que dois homens
trabalhavam numa roça ele chegou perto
depois do cumprimento que é o
cumprimento clássico à distância se faz
hum chegou perto e atividade era uma
atividade bastante curiosa da frente
abrir o buraco
o de trás em seguida fechava o mesmo
buraco o da frente abril de trás fechava
abrir fechava abrir fechava é o pai
curioso chegou perto diz que você está
fazendo meu caro
o primeiro teria dito o serviço meo aqui
hoje abel braga e você entra mesmo ele é
beijar o braga não está faltando nada
entre uma coisa e outra
o acordo é nossa não engorde fará a vida
dos outros poderosos que os homens que
praticamente não vier nós a fazer nossa
parte
eu não quero passar a minha vida abrindo
e fechando o buraco abrindo e fechando o
buraco até que alguém abra e feche o meu
buraco
eu quero tentar continuar a seguir pela
vida ensinando o mundo com as idéias que
eu acredito que seria muito bom que a
gente fizesse isso cada vez mais juntos
a gente inseminar as idéias na terça
feira à tarde que é onde a vida acontece
pra valer que a gente inseminar as
idéias que creiam que creiam que dentro
de semente
guardem essa dentro de sementes
ora árvore dentro de semente mora a
árvore se a gente entende isso e
acredita nisso o que vão pensar de mim o
que vão pensar de mim importam muito
menos porque a gente sai da reclamação a
gente sai do medo do que vão pensar de
nós e vamos em busca da realização do
mundo que queremos e acreditamos o
quanto a gente acredita que dentro de
semente mora árvore mesmo que a gente
não veja e não importa porque é na
semeadura que se dá ao encanto na terça
feira à tarde e eu me despeço de vocês
com uma torcida muito genuína para que a
gente possa caminhar pela vida tendo
essa capacidade tão digna e singela de
andar de cabeça erguida
a espinha ereta sorriso largo de coração
tranqüilo
lamentando - esperando - e amando mais
porque assim talvez a gente consiga
construir o cotidiano tão velho
descontraía nossa identidade e construir
um mundo novo e sempre que quiser de
cabelo solto
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]